[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Jetzt so kurz vor Silvester, habe ich mir gedacht,
machen wir mal wieder einen leckeren Snack.
Vielleicht verbringt ihr ja dieses Jahr Silvester
so im kleinen Kreis zu Hause
und habt dann nachts noch Lust auf einen Snack.
Ich finde es sowieso immer ganz praktisch,
wenn man dann so ein paar verschiedene kleine Dinge hat,
die man einfach den Tag über vorbereiten kann
und dann einfach snacken kann,
wann immer man Hunger hat
und wann immer man möchte.
Heute gibt es kleine Brotsticks
und dazu später einen Nacho-Dip,
also einen Käsedip so wie Nacho-Dip aus dem Kino.
Kenne ich noch von früher.
Jedenfalls mache ich jetzt zuerst mal den Hefeteig.
Und ich mache einen Pizzateig,
werde aber hierfür noch Dinkelmehl und Vollkornmehl
und Hafermehl benutzen
– denn dadurch bekomme ich
einen richtig schönen Geschmack mit rein –
und dann eben noch Kräuter.
Für den Teig verwende ich
einen halben Würfel Hefe,
– das sind 20 Gramm –
einen Teelöffel Dattelsirup,
250 Gramm warmes Wasser.
Hier habe ich meine Mehlmischung.
Ich nehme Dinkelvollkornmehl,
Dinkelmehl 630
und Hafermehl.
Hier habe ich noch Salz, Pfeffer und Oregano
und etwas Olivenöl.
Ich mache das jetzt auch hier ganz einfach
ohne Küchenmaschine.
Ich nehme ein Handrührgerät.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Hefe mit dem Wasser
und Dattelsirup vermischen.
[Musik]
Den Dattelsirup habe ich jetzt als Zuckerersatz.
Also ihr könnt auch einfach ein bisschen Zucker nehmen
oder Honig oder einen anderen Sirup.
Der hilft einfach dabei, dass die Hefe schöner aufgeht,
und bringt auch geschmacklich noch ein bisschen was rein.
Jetzt nehme ich mein Handrührgerät
oder die Hände
oder eine Gabel am Anfang.
Jetzt schon mal ein bisschen Mehl einarbeiten.
Die Gewürze dazu geben.
Ich habe jetzt Oregano, aber ihr könnt auch gern
ein anderes Gewürz nehmen, was ihr gerade dahabt.
Und zum Schluss noch das Öl.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen mehr abgewogen.
Denn das nehme ich gleich noch zum Bestreichen.
Und jetzt aus dem Teig
– oder aus den Zutaten einen schönen Hefeteig kneten.
Und jetzt binden die Zutaten ein bisschen
und ich nehme jetzt gleich die Hände,
weil ein Hefeteig schon ein bisschen zu hart ist
oder zu fest ist für so ein Handrührgerät.
Aber am Anfang ist es immer ganz gut.
Und dann einfach die Hände nehmen.
Den Rest knete ich jetzt per Hand ein.
Und da ich jetzt ein Dinkelvollkornmehl benutzt habe,
brauche ich jetzt bei mir noch ein bisschen Wasser.
Also das müsst ihr auch immer individuell
an eurem Mehl so ein bisschen festmachen.
Wenn der Teig noch zu fest ist,
noch ein bisschen Wasser einarbeiten.
Und dann in etwa fünf bis zehn Minuten
schön geschmeidig verkneten.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
kann ich mir Fotos auf Sarahs Kamera anschauen.
>> SARAH: Passt?
>> SALLY: Und während Josh filmt, kann ich weiterkneten.
Ja, passt.
>> JOSH: Bis gleich!
>> SALLY: Bis gleich!
Warte. Wir machen so einen YouTuber-Übergang, Josh.
Komm.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Du kommst mit der Kamera ran
und ich gehe mit der Hand so ran.
Natürlich darf man das nicht ankündigen
bei so einem coolen Kameraübergang aber.
Yo, ich knete jetzt den Teig hier weiter zehn Minuten.
Wir sehen uns gleich, yo.
Yo! Wir sind wieder zurück.
Der Teig ist jetzt geknetet.
Den forme ich zu einer Kugel.
Ich mache wieder meine Übergänge.
Aber ich habe es probiert.
Ich habe es probiert.
Wäre ich jetzt so ein krasser YouTuber, würde ich sagen:
"Was waren die krassesten Übergänge,
die ihr je erlebt habt?"
Egal.
Okay.
Dann kann ich hier die Schüssel
leicht fetten,
die Kugel hineinlegen
und dann den Teig abgedeckt
an einem warmen Ort für eine Stunde aufgehen lassen
oder im Backofen bei Gärstufe
bei 34°C.
Da trocknet die Oberfläche nämlich nicht aus
und der Teig braucht nur eine halbe Stunde zum Aufgehen.
Hi, Murat!
>> MURAT: So.
Ich komme gerade von der Baustelle.
>> SALLY: Und? Wie läuft es?
>> MURAT: Mh.
Es gibt immer Probleme auf der Baustelle.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, es ist halt so.
Ja, selbst zwischen den Jahren jetzt so kurz vor Silvester,
selbst dann gibt es immer noch Baustellenprobleme.
>> MURAT: Ja, jeder, der mal gebaut hat, weiß, dass
vieles schieflaufen kann.
>> SALLY: Ja, jetzt über Weihnachten sowieso.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Wieso erwähnst du eigentlich immer dauernd,
dass Weihnachten ist?
>> SALLY: Weil wir vorproduzieren für Silvester.
>> MURAT: Ah! Ach so, okay.
Frohe Weihnachten!
Es ist Weihnachten.
>> SALLY: Kannst du mir den Ofen aufmachen?
>> MURAT: Ich mache den Ofen auf, Baby.
So. Bitte schön.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, auf der Baustelle
gibt es immer wieder Probleme.
Ich weiß, das interessiert euch nicht,
weil ihr euch für das Rezept interessiert.
Aber manchmal passieren Sachen,
die glaubt man gar nicht.
Hört mich eigentlich jemand?
>> JOSH: Nein, nicht wirklich.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich weiß, das interessiert euch nicht.
Euch interessiert das Rezept.
Aber draußen ist es kalt,
weil es Weihnachten ist, und es schneit.
Und auf der Baustelle passieren manchmal Sachen,
die sind unglaublich, wirklich.
Und es wird
meistens dann auch teurer.
>> SALLY: Echt jetzt?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
>> SALLY: Josh.
>> JOSH: Tschu!
>> SALLY: Tschu!
Hier habe ich jetzt den Teig.
Der durfte ruhen.
Ich habe ihn jetzt leider schon ohne die Kamera
hier flach gedrückt.
>> JOSH: Mhm, wir können es dir nicht verzeihen.
>> SALLY: Es tut mir so...
Okay, soll ich es noch mal machen?
>> JOSH: Nee, ist okay.
>> SALLY: Daraus werde ich jetzt, denke ich mal, zwölf
– nee, ich mache 16 Brotsticks.
Oder zwölf?
Oder 16?
16.
>> JOSH: So ein Snack muss ja klein und viel sein.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber auch schön lang.
Das ist schon gut.
Oh, das sieht so schön aus!
Jetzt schon einfach so backen.
>> JOSH: Ja, auch voll gut.
>> SALLY: Einfach so backen und abreißen.
Oh!
Du warst da noch nicht da,
da habe ich mal so eine Pestoblume gemacht
und eine Nutella-Blume.
Ich finde, es wird Zeit für eine
Nougatblume.
>> JOSH: Ach, das ist aber nicht nötig.
Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Doch, Josh. Doch.
>> JOSH: Meinst du?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, zu deinem Einstand so nach einem Jahr.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, jetzt habe ich hier
das Ganze nämlich einfach
– zack, zack! 16 Teile,
alles gleich groß.
Schön, oder?
Das ist so richtig satisfying.
Und diese einzelnen Portionen
müssen dann gleich noch mal durch drei geteilt werden.
Denn ich möchte die Brotsticks
flechten.
Müsst ihr nicht, aber ich finde es schon recht schön.
Also theoretisch, wenn ihr es jetzt einfach machen wollt,
nehmt ihr sie, zieht sie so ein bisschen auseinander
oder ihr rollt sie eckig aus und schneidet es einfach.
Aber ich finde, man kann die
jetzt auch so richtig schön machen.
Und zwar habe ich mir vorgestellt:
die so durch drei.
Ich muss jetzt nur sagen, dass durch das Vollkornmehl
der Teig jetzt nicht so ganz megaelastisch ist.
Aber es klappt, denke ich, trotzdem.
Ich finde, es muss halt nicht immer nur so helles Mehl sein.
Es darf auch mal so ein bisschen dunkles Mehl sein.
Und vor allem Hafermehl ist auch cool.
Und jetzt hier schön gleichmäßig.
Und dann einen Zopf flechten.
Also immer von außen in die Mitte.
Und am Ende hier unten
so ein bisschen zusammendrücken.
Und oben müsst ihr halt so ein bisschen umgedreht,
umgekehrt
denken.
Aber
gut, dass es 16 sind.
Sonst wäre das riesig geworden.
Man hätte es sogar halbieren können
und halb so lang.
Schon.
Ich mache unten noch welche.
Also ihr könnt sie auch noch kleiner machen.
Dann könnt ihr so
so Habibis machen, so kleine.
Jetzt machen wir einfach so ein halbstündiges Video,
wie ich aus Teig Zöpfe flechte,
immer so perfekte Zöpfe.
[Musik]
Guckt einmal, wie schön die sind!
Und die sind echt gut, dass wir sie so klein gemacht haben.
Jetzt bestreiche ich sie noch mal mit Olivenöl.
Und ich muss sagen,
dass der Teig sich hervorragend eignet zum Flechten,
also tatsächlich besser als gedacht.
Ich muss sagen, da so ein süßer Hefeteig irgendwie
gefällt mir da nicht so gut,
wenn ich so Brioche oder so mache.
Aber der Teig, so der Pizzateig ist echt perfekt
mit dem Vollkornmehl.
Jetzt kurz mit Öl bestreichen
und dann kommen sie direkt in den Backofen
und werden gebacken.
Entweder könnt ihr sie jetzt weich backen
oder tatsächlich auch knusprig backen.
Das heißt, entweder so lange drin lassen, bis sie gar sind,
oder ein bisschen über den Garpunkt,
dass sie knusprig werden.
Und wer möchte, kann sie auch jetzt
noch mal mit Kräutern bestreuen.
Sarah, wollen wir das?
>> SARAH: Wir wollen es.
>> SALLY: Wir wollen es? Okay.
Dann bestreuen wir sie noch mal mit Kräutern.
Aber ihr müsst nicht.
Aber ihr könnt.
Ach, schön!
[Musik]
Während die Brotsticks jetzt noch backen,
werde ich schon mal die Käsesoße zubereiten.
Ich mache das Ganze jetzt mit Cheddar-Käse,
weil der schon von sich aus eine tolle Farbe hat.
Aber ihr könnt auch einfach euren Lieblingskäse nehmen.
Das Ganze baut auf einer Béchamelsoße auf,
also eine Soße, die aus so einem Mehl-
– aus einer Mehlschwitze besteht mit Milch
und da kommt der Käse rein.
Ich nehme dafür jetzt
30 Gramm Butter,
30 Gramm Mehl,
250 Gramm Milch,
etwas Cheddar-Käse,
Salz,
Pfeffer
und Cayennepfeffer.
>> SARAH: So viel esse ich in fünf Monaten nicht!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Aber...
>> SALLY: Ach deswegen!
Ja, was meinst du, was in dem Käsedip drin ist,
den man im Kino bekommt?
>> SARAH: Viel Cheddar-Käse,
aber dann heißt es halt "viel"
und nicht "etwas".
>> SALLY: Okay.
Reden wir nicht weiter über die Käsemenge.
Starten wir direkt.
Ich mache das jetzt hier in dem Minigusseisen.
Denn darin werde ich den Käsedip auch servieren
und dann brauche ich nicht noch
einen zweiten Topf dreckig machen.
Ich hoffe, nur dass die Soße reinpasst.
Aber ich bin zuversichtlich.
Jetzt kurz
– der Josh ist skeptisch.
Nee, er ist realistisch.
Jetzt kurz die Butter mit dem Mehl erhitzen
und leicht bräunlich anbraten.
Die Mehlschwitze.
Warum heißt sie Mehlschwitze?
Weil das Mehl schwitzt.
[Musik]
Mmh!
Jetzt beginnt es lecker zu duften.
Ach, komm, Sarah.
Komm. Bevor du da rumstehst,
komm, schütte mir die Milch rein.
>> SARAH: Ich stehe nicht rum. Ich warte auf dich.
>> SALLY: Komm.
>> JOSH: Die Ausrede finde ich gut.
>> SALLY: Warte kurz.
Lass es noch ein bisschen hellbraun werden.
>> SARAH: Das ist gelb.
>> SALLY: Riecht gut, gell?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mehlschwitze.
>> SARAH: Mein Papa hat das früher immer gemacht.
>> SALLY: Béchamel?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Nee, für die...
Für unser Weihnachtsessen die Madeirasoße.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Kann der Thomas mich mal einladen?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Der Thomas lädt dich gern ein.
Aber dann gibt es Zunge.
>> SALLY: Nee.
No, no, no!
Okay, jetzt ist es hellbraun.
>> SARAH: Kann ich?
>> SALLY: Jetzt vorsichtig die Milch reingießen.
>> SARAH: War das ein...
So.
Muss ich es auskratzen?
Oder belassen wir es dabei?
>> SALLY: Ach, ist okay.
Ohne Teigschaber. Ja.
Bei so ganz flüssigen Dingen ist es okay.
Jetzt kannst du mir noch die Gewürze reinmachen.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Lassen wir uns heute mal bedienen, oder?
>> SARAH: Aber schön angeordnet.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> SARAH: Alles auf einmal?
>> SALLY: Alles auf einmal.
Nee, erst Pfeffer bitte.
Dann Cayennepfeffer.
Und dann Salz.
Oh!
Und jetzt die Soße aufkochen lassen
und immer schön rühren,
damit sie nicht anbrennt.
>> SARAH: Guck mal hier auf das Bild.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Kannst du mir das noch mal so schön machen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Und dann noch etwas Cheddar.
>> SALLY: Kannst du den schon mal zupfen?
Wir sind doch ein Team!
>> SARAH: Ja. Ich wasche mir die Hände.
Jetzt zupft die ohne mich!
>> SALLY: Ja, ich warte doch auch auf dich.
Wir haben doch noch genug Käse.
Josh, was würdest du sagen?
>> JOSH: Habt ihr genug Topf?
>> SALLY: Man hätte jetzt auch
natürlich einen größeren Topf nehmen können.
Aber ich will, dass die Käsesoße später da drinnen ist.
>> SARAH: Wie klein hättest du es denn gern?
>> SALLY: So passt.
Der schmilzt doch, oder?
>> SARAH: Wäre von Vorteil.
>> SALLY: Ach, wenn der nicht schmilzt, weiß ich auch nicht.
Cheddar hat eine gute Schmelzeigenschaft.
Deswegen habe ich Cheddar genommen.
Und weil er eben eine tolle Farbe hat
und einen guten Geschmack.
Guck mal, wie schön sich die Farbe verändert.
Guck, guck, guck, guck!
Okay.
Haben wir genug Topf für so viel Käse?
>> SARAH:. Ja. Aber es sieht sehr zähflüssig aus.
Muss da noch Flüssigkeit dazu?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich muss dazu sagen,
der wird ja jetzt noch flüssiger durch den Käse.
>> SARAH: Soll ich noch mehr reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wenn man das jetzt ganz frisch zubereitet,
dann passt es mit der Flüssigkeitsmenge.
Wenn man den aber vorbereitet,
und dann noch mal erwärmen will,
kann es sein, dass man einfach noch mal Milch dazu gibt.
>> SARAH: Komm, das passt noch rein.
>> SALLY: Das passt noch.
>> SARAH: Du bist doch ein Profi.
>> SALLY: Du auch.
>> SARAH: Das kam – das ging lang.
>> SALLY: Ich musst erst mal
deine Wörter im Kopf verarbeiten.
Ja, so kurz vor dem Jahreswechsel
sind die Gedanken halt nicht mehr so geordnet.
Da hat man das ganze Jahr so im Kopf und dann...
>> SARAH: So geht es mir auch
gerade momentan.
Ich verliere den ganzen Käse auf dem Weg.
>> SALLY: Okay. Sobald der Käse geschmolzen ist
und die Brotsticks, die Rapunzelsticks fertig sind,
werden wir verkosten.
Und Josh so: "Wann kann ich die Kamera weglegen?"
>> JOSH: Ja, schon okay. Lass dir ruhig Zeit.
>> SALLY: Aber ich wollte dir nur zeigen, Josh,
dass der ganze Käse hier reingepasst hat.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Ich...
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> JOSH: Ich nehme meinen Hate zurück.
>> SALLY: Danke.
>> SARAH: Kommentar gelöscht.
>> SALLY: Perfect!
Aber er muss noch ein bisschen schmelzen.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Bis gleich!
>> SARAH: Der ist zu zäh.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ui!
So sieht er schon gut aus.
Aber, was ich tatsächlich vergessen habe
oder was mir jetzt erst eingefallen ist,
ich verfeinere den Dip noch mit Knoblauch.
Entweder könnt ihr jetzt die Knoblauchzehe fein reiben
oder einfach halbieren.
So mache ich es jetzt.
Halbieren,
reinschmeißen
und einfach ziehen lassen.
Und dann wird es eine Knoblauch-Käse-Soße.
Oh yes!
[Musik]
Guck mal. Jetzt machen wir so kleine Brotsticks.
Die nennt man auch Rapunzel- oder Elsazopf.
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Guck, jetzt halbierst du einen.
So die Hälfte, damit es zwei kleine Kugeln werden.
Und dann machst du so.
>> ELA: Und dann zuerst das da machen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Dann rollen.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt haben wir drei große.
Und wenn wir jetzt alle halbieren,
wie viele haben wir dann?
Mh.
Wir können rechnen oder zählen.
>> ELA: Eins.
Mh.
>> SALLY: Ja, das hast du schon halbiert.
Jetzt noch das halbieren
und das hier halbieren.
Das war ja schon. Das hier ist eins.
Die sollen ja gleich groß sein.
Genau. Das jetzt auch noch durch zwei.
Und das auch durch zwei.
Wir hatten drei große
und wie viele haben wir jetzt, wie viele kleine?
>> ELA: Ich sage es dir nicht.
Du musst das alleine
durchrechnen.
>> SALLY: So.
Wie viele haben wir jetzt?
>> ELA: Du machst das irgendwie nicht richtig.
>> SALLY: Oh, Entschuldigung.
>> ELA: Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
>> SALLY: Super!
>> ELA: Sechs.
>> SALLY: Und guck mal.
Jetzt brauchen wir drei Stück erst mal.
Und jetzt nimmst du einen
und machst so einen langen Strang.
Wir flechten die nämlich jetzt wie so Armbändchen
oder wie einen Zopf in den Haaren.
>> ELA: Ah! Wie einen Elsazopf, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> ELA: Hm, hm.
>> SALLY: Elsazopf!
Die kannst du auch mit zur Schule nehmen
oder zum Kindergarten.
Gehst du schon zur Schule?
>> ELA: Nee!
Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
Ich mache ein Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> ELA: Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
>> SALLY: Soll ich dir helfen oder machst du alleine?
>> ELA: Ich mache es alleine.
>> SALLY: Okay. Guck so, einfach drei Stück.
>> ELA: Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
>> SALLY: Weißt du, wie man einen Zopf flechtet?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Super.
>> ELA: Müssen die alle gleich groß sein?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Oje.
>> ELA: Oje!
Ojemine!
>> SALLY: Guck mal, wenn es mal in der Mitte zu dünn wird,
kannst du es einfach wieder so zusammenfalten,
so drüber,
und so noch mal rollen.
Und dann wird es wieder gleich. Guck.
Ja, gleichmäßig, nicht?
Genau.
Und wenn du drei Stück hast, sag mir Bescheid.
Wie viel fehlt dir noch?
>> ELA: Mh.
Eins.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
>> SALLY: Voll gut!
Einen noch.
>> ELA: Ich glaube, ich verdrehe das ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ja, das macht nichts.
Das ist – es muss nicht ganz genau.
Guck, meine sind auch nicht ganz genau.
Haare sind ja auch nicht immer gleich lang.
Mal kürzer, mal länger.
>> ELA: Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
Wabbel-Wabbel-Würmchen!
>> SALLY: Machst du im Kindergarten auch viel mit Knete?
>> ELA: Mh.
Das ist doch gar keine Knete.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist Teig.
>> ELA: Wir haben gar keine Knete im Kindergarten.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Echt?
Ah, vielleicht jetzt wegen...
Okay.
Stimmt.
>> ELA: Aber nicht wegen Corona.
>> SALLY: Nicht wegen Corona?
Weiß auch alles, gell?
Das Kind weiß alles.
Okay.
So. Jetzt nimmst du drei Stück
und legst sie so vor dir hin.
Guck mal. Und da oben machst du sie so zusammen, ja?
Zack, zack.
Und jetzt immer – guck mal.
Genau. Guck. Aber guck mal bei mir zu.
Schau mal zu, Ela. Hallo!
Hallo!
Guck mal, einmal von rechts rein in die Mitte.
Dann von links in die Mitte.
Von rechts in die Mitte, von links in die Mitte.
>> ELA: Aha!
>> SALLY: Aha.
Guck mal.
Das von hier außen
in die Mitte legen.
Und jetzt das.
Aber in die Mitte.
Guck, nicht hierhin, sondern in die Mitte.
Und jetzt wieder von rechts in die Mitte,
hier rein.
Schön.
Jetzt von links in die Mitte.
>> ELA: Geh mal weg.
Das mache ich.
>> SALLY: Ja, in die Mitte.
Und von rechts in die Mitte.
Oh! In die Mitte, Schatz. In die Mitte.
Und von links in die Mitte.
Und von rechts in die Mitte.
Und wieder
– nein, in die Mitte.
Hier, guck.
Nicht nach außen,
sondern in die Mitte rein.
Und genau.
Und schon
hast du deinen Brotstick!
>> ELA: Und so hast du es immer um.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und dann lege ich es auf Blech
– auf das Blech.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und du kannst weitermachen.
Super!
>> ELA: Eins.
Können wir eine Hundepfote machen?
>> SALLY: Eine Hundepfote?
>> ELA: Ja.
Wir machen das mit kleinen
und großen Schokoladenstückchen.
Außen sollen...
Guck, eine...
>> SALLY: Wie wäre es, wenn wir jetzt hier
erst mal die Elsazöpfe flechten?
>> ELA: Und dann...
>> SALLY: Und mit einem anderen Teig machen wir
wann anders Hundepfötchen, ja?
Joshi-Pfötchen.
>> ELA: Ja, die Joshi-Pfötchen.
Soll ich dir sagen, wie das geht, kurz?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Du machst einen
– mh –
Lebkuchenteig.
Dann, guck,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: so ganz groß.
Guck, du machst das so.
Und dann...
Guck, dann machst du
>> SALLY: Ja, ich gucke.
>> ELA: eine große Kugel.
Dann machst du so.
Und dann machst du hier die kleinen Schokoladenstückchen
und hier ein großes.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Dann machen wir mal so Hundepfoten, okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber heute machen wir noch unsere Zöpfe fertig,
das Brot.
Probierst du gleich?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Wow!
Ich habe gerade vier gemacht.
>> SALLY: Wow!
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Ela, kannst du gut pfeifen?
[Ela pfeift]
Das klingt ja sehr gut!
>> SALLY: Wie ein Vögelchen.
>> ELA: Ich habe gerade Ja gesagt.
>> SALLY: Heißt das in Vogelsprache Ja?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nein.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Heute haben wir einen Brotzopf gemacht.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Sieht aus wie Rapunzelzöpfe, gell?
Oder?
>> ELA: Elsazöpfe.
>> SALLY: Elsazöpfe!
Komm, wir probieren mal.
Ah, du probierst schon.
Darf ich von der anderen Hälfte probieren?
Ich esse mit Käsedip.
Du? Mit oder ohne?
>> ELA: Ohne,
glaube ich.
Ich will mal probieren.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Man schmeckt den...
Ist gut?
Und?
Schmeckt es dir?
Schmeckt der andere Käsedip von Mama besser,
der, den wir immer zum Frühstück machen?
Ja, die Ela ist halt unseren Frühstückskäsedip gewohnt
mit Gazi Beyaz Peynir,
also mit Weichkäse und Sahne.
Und das ist halt ein Cheddar-Dip.
Aber ich finde den echt gut
und ich finde, der schmeckt gut nach Knoblauch.
Ich habe eben Sarah gefragt so:
"Sarah, schmeckt der nach Knoblauch?"
Und sie so: "Nö."
Aber ich finde schon.
>> SARAH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ich finde, das kommt voll durch.
>> SARAH: Ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Krass!
Eigentlich hätte ja ich, die Türkin,
den Knoblauch nicht rausschmecken dürfen.
>> SARAH: Ich bin jetzt doch auch Hobby-Türkin.
>> SALLY: Du bist Hobby-Türkin?
Wahnsinn.
Wahnsinn!
Ela, gönn dir den Zopf.
Nimmst du die morgen mit zur Schule
– mit zum Kindergarten?
Jetzt sage ich schon wieder Schule.
Jetzt habe ich schon wieder Schule gesagt,
weil ich gedacht habe, du bist schon so groß.
Hm?
Ela will nicht mehr sprechen,
nur noch essen.
>> ELA: Stimmt doch gar nicht!
>> SALLY: Hm!
Und wenn jetzt die Zuschauer
das Rezept nachmachen wollen,
wo gibt es das Rezept?
>> ELA: In sallys-blog.de!
>> SALLY: Juhu!
>> ELA: Den.
>> SALLY: War das so ein YouTuber-Move?
>> ELA: Mhm.
Ich meinte damit nur bei sallys-blog.de.
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> ELA: Deswegen habe ich hier unten gezeigt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und sollen die mal alles was kommentieren
oder abonnieren oder so?
Was?
>> ELA: Unsere Videos!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay.
>> ELA: Hast du viele Werbungen?
>> SALLY: Nee, ich habe nicht viel Werbung.
>> ELA: Hast du eine Werbung?
>> SALLY: Ja, eine.
Aber manchmal macht YouTube aus Versehen Werbung rein.
Da kann ich dann nichts dafür.
Ich mache die dann halt aus.
Wieso?
Es gibt Kanäle, die haben ganz viel Werbung, nicht?
Das nervt dann, gell?
Okay.
Willst du noch was sagen oder machen wir aus?
[Ela grunzt]
Du kleines Schweinchen.
Noch Tschüss?
>> ELA: Tschüss.
>> SALLY: Prost.
Einen Kuss.
Einen Brotkuss.
>> ELA: Ih!
Warte.
[Musik]